well I'm sure now by the presence of the
CVI Paul dresser so Paul good evening to
you you're off to give a speech in the
city straight after this during which
you say brexit uncertainty looms over
almost every aspect of doing business in
the UK every companies are having to
plan for the worst while hoping for the
best if you had anything at all this
week's that give you come gives you
comfort well I mean I think there are a
number of different things that we have
to be focused on at the moment the
number one priority is making sufficient
progress with the EU so we can get into
discussions about the future so that's
the overriding priority significant
progress has clearly been made in a
number of those areas there is a final
area to sort out great leadership from
Ireland north and south and the UK I'm
sure will solve this issue and get us
into talking about the future do you
think we're getting that great
leadership right now I think it's going
to be tested over the next four or five
days I'd be happy to answer that next
week one of the things that I'm sure
mentioned earlier verochka has been
speaking to Teresa made her softening
I mean elsewhere he has said separately
it may well be that phase two talks ie
on trade has to go into next German that
is not what business wants to hear is it
look I think it is in everybody's
interest that we make rapid progress
there has been a lot of talk over the
past 12 months but we still have today 4
million EU citizens who don't know where
they stand going into their second
Christmas without an unconditional
guarantee about the future that is just
not acceptable we've had a long period
of uncertainty that at this point in
time means we're already in two
companies implementing the contingency
plans we know from research we did about
a month ago that about 10% of companies
have already started to make decisions
around investment and around people that
will not favor the UK by the end of the
year we know that would be an additional
25% by the end of March over 60% of
companies that have actually got
international interests with which will
be impacted by this uncertainty will
have to put in place contingency plans
they will not be in favor of UK jobs
investment in the next generation and
that will be by the first quarter of
next year you think those plans will
starts have implement those plans are
already been implemented be a no doubt
the train has left the station decisions
have been taken today business works 24
hours a day seven days a week we have to
take decisions on a continuous basis and
for many of those businesses the time
taken to prepare for what might happen
post March 19 is such that they have to
start making those plans and executing
those plans today so every day that's
delayed costs everybody right across the
whole of Europe in terms of its cost
implications now one of the comments
we've heard a lot of what David Davis
said another thing that he said during
their that hearing research he thought
he hinted today of further regulatory
alignment with the EU specifically for
the financial services sector has i
meanthat's presume that's pretty good
news for the city what look the the City
of London makes a vital contribution to
UK economy about 11% of our GDP comes
from financial services so it's an
incredibly important part of our whole
economy but at this stage in the game we
need to understand the costs and the
benefits the pros and the cons of every
decision that we take in relation to the
brexit that's what any good business
does for significant decisions and I
expect our cabinets do the same I mean
one thing that's poor I mean a lot of
people are gonna say hang on is it this
is just more shroud waving from the CBI
about brexit I look I don't think I
would be a period this evening if I
didn't care about this issue I've had
meetings with business people this
morning
last week every time I meet with
business people the level of concern is
rising the uncertainty is beyond a level
that we can tolerate and ignore and I
know decisions have been taken and the
one thing that I guarantee you is in 40
years in business nobody has ever made
announcements about decisions on
investments that are going to make or
people they're not going to employ the
consequences of this uncertainty will be
felt in 12 to 18 months time and it's
our duty to minimize the negative
impacts of those I pulled Russia off and
the CBO I appreciate you joining me
thank you thank you